in the midst of everything happening
with the supreme court we learned last
week through this leaked decision that
in all likelihood unless something
changes the current supreme court is
going to be voting to overturn roe v
wade as soon as the end of june in the
midst of all of this protests at the
houses of supreme court justices etc etc
and of course the search for the leaker
which i really wonder how that's going
um public confidence in the supreme
court has absolutely collapsed from
where it was
there is a new poll
confidence in supreme court collapsed
since conservatives took control
this is a new yahoo news yougov poll
which shows that over the last 20 months
american confidence in the court
has collapsed this is a period that
started with trump and republicans
putting in that 6-3 conservative
majority with the replacement of ruth
bader ginsburg by amy coney barrett
and that
this has culminated with the leak of the
draft signaling that roe v wade will be
overturned the last time yahoo yougov
asked about confidence in the court was
september of 2020 that was just a few
days after ruth bader ginsburg died then
70 percent of registered voters said
they had some or a lot of confidence in
the court
whereas 30 said they had a little or
none
in the new survey
a 40 40-point swing where now only half
of voters expect some or a lot of
confidence
while the other half now expresses a
little or no support
that is uh those are incredible numbers
and as the article points out views on
key aspects of american life
rarely shift that suddenly
and the question is why
the question is why
now there's tons of speculation as to
why but one important element of this to
understand
is that we now have
five of the nine justices on the court
appointed by presidents who lost the
popular vote so just take a step back
for a second
most americans believe that abortion
should be legal in most cases
americans are more in favor of abortion
today than at any point during the roe v
wade era and we have this forthcoming
decision where the supreme court is
going to say no we're getting rid of roe
v wade abortion isn't even going to be a
right anymore okay well let's look at
the makeup it's a 6-3 conservative court
in which five of the nine justices were
chosen by presidents who lost the
popular vote george w bush selected
chief justice roberts and samuel alito
donald trump selected
neil gorsuch brett kavanaugh and amy
coney barrett five of the nine the loser
of the popular vote got to pick okay
that's number one
number two
those choices again made by a president
who lost the popular vote were confirmed
by a completely anti-democratic senate
in which california with 30 something
million people
and wyoming with under a million people
i hope i'm getting these population
numbers correct 30 something million one
under one million
california and wyoming have the same
number of votes
consider the lopsided and undemocratic
nature of this and of course we have to
also say
one of those seats should have been
barack obama's choice should have been
merrick garland but thanks to mitch
mcconnell from the completely
anti-democratic senate being able to
obstruct that nomination long enough for
donald trump to eventually install neil
gorsuch so
it makes sense
that
with such a prominent decision now in
the forefront
you would have
americans saying i i don't i'm not
confident in this court i don't approve
of what this court is doing and
some you know coleman hughes yesterday
said
it's a feature of the supreme court that
it is sort of insulated from public
pressure public opinion etc
that's fine that would be a feature to
me as well as as i thought about it
overnight i came to this realization
that's all well and good
assuming we're confident about the way
we got to these nine people on the court
and and i'm not
i'm not i mean again
two presidents who lost the popular vote
got to decide
thanks to
the votes from republican senators from
disproportionately lower population
states
giving these republican senators outsize
influence i'm going from memory here and
don't hold me to this but we looked at a
statistic where something
like oh my i think it was senator in you
could have a situation where you have a
majority in the senate
with the senators that represent only 17
percent of the american population
because of that population skew i hope
that makes sense
um so it makes sense to me that you are
seeing this swing as many have noted you
don't usually see such significant
swings on major issues of public opinion
something that it's not every day people
don't think every day about do i do i
have confidence in the supreme court or
don't i that's not something most people
think about every day people are busy
living their lives and working and to
see such a drastic swing
in such a short period of time isn't
common and so on the one hand
it's good in that lots of people seem to
be paying attention to something that
they often wouldn't
on the other hand
we don't really have much recourse here
and that's by design and that would be
fine assuming we felt good about the
process i don't and i'm curious to hear
from you
what if you could get through an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist takes top non-fiction books in
every genre boils them down into a text
or audio explainer that you can consume
in 15 minutes of course blinkist would
never replace reading real books in
their entirety but blinkist lets you
absorb the most important insights from
the non-fiction books you wouldn't
otherwise have time for i have a ton of
different ways i consume information and
blinkist is one of those and it's super
efficient i just used blinkist to listen
to the book toxic positivity
super interesting just about this like
happiness obsessed culture that now we
live in got through it in 15 minutes
with all of the key points blinkist also
takes tons of popular podcasts and
creates a 15-minute explainer for each
episode and blinkist really just
empowers you to grow by discovering new
ideas knowledge that will give you
valuable new perspectives about the
world go to blinkist.com pacman to try
blinkist free for seven days and you'll
get 25 off a premium subscription that's
just 625 a month the link is down below